it's the end of the season my brain is
fried and I honestly can't think of a
quippy intro so let's just go roll that
sweet water secrets intro here we are
river babes
I'm your host Liana Galera but I think
you know that by now and this is the
Sweetwater Secrets after-show for the
season 2 finale chapter 35 brave new
world now although this episode was
still great I will say it was a bit
underwhelming compared to that
mind-blowing completely bonkers
penultimate episode now I'm still gonna
be gifting you with my hisses and kisses
plus exclusive interviews from the cast
including behind the scenes scoop from
Vanessa Morgan and Madeline Peck talking
about some deleted Shoni scenes that
were apparently too hot to handle and
make sure you keep watching this video
till the very end because I have two big
surprises for you river babes
but first let's very quickly recap the
biggest headlines on the episode in the
blue and gold breakdown now after
initially trying to break our hearts
with a scene of Archie Veronica and
Betty crying over jugheads grave
Riverdale pulled the old dream sequence
twist and revealed that Jughead is a-ok
now we also got plenty of other good
news like the fact that fangs is
apparently alive and that the Serpent's
although badly beaten and now homeless
are standing together if P was fired
from Pop's thanks a lot
Hiram and jugs dad fell off the wagon
there a little bit but after he saw his
son risk everything to save the
remaining Serpent's f peace faith was
restored he then decided to retire for
real this time
and he named Jughead as the new king of
the serpents my boy has never stopped
fighting for this group but that's not
all
Sheryl was the first new serpent to
slither into a hot new jacket and
Jughead asked Betty a very important
question
that is surfing yes when I go you felt
about being my queen
did you love that oh me too so here's
what Lily Reinhart had to tell me about
Betty and her mom embracing their
serpent ways in season 2 I love that
Betty and her mom are really kind of
embracing their serpent sides what was
your reaction to that I mean I'm all for
it you know Betty's proud to be the jug
and you know she's happy to see her mom
kind of owning her serpent heritage and
her bad side and I think everyone kind
of wanted to see Alison that way because
it's so appealing because she's so
different from that in her daily life so
I don't know I think fans are really
gonna love that I really love that I
love to see when you know Betty kind of
works hand in hand with the serpent
Sweet Pea and fangs and everybody
meanwhile things with the black hood
were frustrating to be honest Hal was
safely locked behind bars but he still
tried his best to get inside Betty's
head he'll be back Betty
and as for that copycat black hood who
tried to shoot Fred Andrews yeah Sheriff
what's-his-name casually explained to
Archie that they already caught and
killed the other black hood and it
turned out to be tall boy that's it
that's the big black hood reveal that we
waited all season for say it with me now
lame-o that is wack lastly the mayoral
race in the quest for student body
president were still on Archie ended up
securing the win at Riverdale high but
unfortunately it was not a double
Andrews victory because Fred lost to
Hermione but at least she was gracious
about it I came to tell Fred that he ran
a great campaign Veronica
used Super Lawyer McCoy to get her money
back from Hiram and then bought the
white worm and then traded it to Hiram
in exchange for Pop's diner the catch
Veronica is now completely cut off from
her daddy's wallet it's all blood money
anyway
as for Hiram he now has a new band of
uber goobers who are planning on
wreaking havoc in Riverdale starting
with Archie's arrest now if you're
confused I was - they're talking about
that guy from the core force cabin
getaway who tried to mug them Andre was
actually the one who killed him but now
that Andre is dead Hiram's trying to pin
the death on
sorry red but you shouldn't have lied
and tried to act like you're the one who
killed the kid a few episodes ago when
some hillbilly threatened mr. lodges
daughter at his safe house I took care
of him too okay now let's turn our
attention to our final seven seconds and
heaven of this season Veronica and
Archie had their end of the season
rendezvous a few episodes back but we
are still treated to a little of Archie
PDA meanwhile Betty and Jughead and
gifted fans with a sultry scene in bed
at the five seasons were you bug head
fans completely freaking out over that
scene well then I have good news for you
stick with me to the end of this video
for an awesomely special surprise as for
the other romances in Riverdale who else
was picking up on some lingering vibes
between Fred and Hermione's hmm now as
for Shoni I totally loved the fact that
Sherrill is now officially a serpent but
I was wildly disappointed that Cheryl
and Tony didn't share more swoon worthy
scenes together they were supposed to so
I did a little digging and here's what
Madeline Pech and Vanessa Morgan had to
tell me about some deleted Shoni scenes
I had Madeline in here a few weeks ago
and we were talking about the fact that
Cheryl is gonna become a serpent and she
had mentioned that tawny is living with
Cheryl and Nana Rose and thistle house I
think as far as its playing her and Tony
will be one man arose so I know but we
didn't end up seeing that in the finale
yeah there a moment that was cut from
the script
well the moment that was cut from the
episode was you know me just showing up
to her house like me pulling up in my
motorcycle chorus and I went up to the
door and I have my bag and I just like
smile at her and she's like welcome home
so when they were like totally moving
and was sure I was like yeah but you
know we didn't up keeping it I think
that's a great idea I think that you
know that gives us season three to
explore their explore relationship and
from getting super serious moving in
together you know that could maybe lead
to bad things but such a new couple I
wish you could have read the original
script it was
which original script for the end
episode okay there's some fun stuff in
there yeah I I was surprised it in the
finale we didn't have as many show me
smooches that I was anticipating no it
was written in but a lot of things
didn't make it I really think we're
saving all the Shoni for season three I
really do that's what I've been told
anyways the way I can describe a season
three same thing see what happens now
let's turn our attention to my hisses
and kisses for the finale hisses to the
new sheriff um I don't like you so I'm
not even gonna bother learning your name
but hisses to the fact that apparently
the second black hood was tall boy we
didn't even get to see him like I said
last week no body no believe it hisses
to Hiram for sinking so low that he had
to have a teenager arrested in order to
feel like a man in fact he says to all
of Hiram's little minions in the white
worm disney villains are scarier than
this pathetic little bunch that's right
hey sister Polly for wanting to forgive
hell and for hiding something up her
little hippie sleeves I don't know who
you want to bring to town from the farm
girl but something tells me you don't
have Alice's best interests at heart
she's been through enough leave her
alone hisses to the fact that at this
point it's like they've drained all the
power from Hermione what happened to the
boss lady who hired the fake FBI agent
what happened to be in the one who was
really pulling the strings I'm glad that
she tipped off Veronica but come on
hashtag free Hermione hisses to that
super mean dream sequence with Betty
crying at jugheads grave but on the flip
side kisses to the fact that jugheads
alive also I'm not really sure how much
time passed in this episode but his
bruises healed very quickly sexually I'm
not even mad that's amazing kisses to FP
for passing the serpent crown over to
his son too Jughead for ushering in a
new coil of snakes
a coil is what you call a group of
snakes science and kisses to the fact
that Betty is getting what she's been
searching for all season you're gonna
let Gorge in that leather jacket girl oh
and kisses to Betty for standing up to
her father and showing him that his
darkness is not going to infect her life
kisses to Veronica for standing by the
Andrews family and for giving us a new
nightclub set to look forward to in
season 3 I want to reopen that speakeasy
kisses to Josie for making a triumphant
turn we missed you girl but we're sorry
that your song got cut short and kisses
to Kevin and Musa for finally locking
lips now I'm not gonna lie the timing
was a little bizarre he was just crying
about midge I don't know but at least
Kevin's finally getting some lovin and
lastly kisses to Cheryl for putting her
own bellossom twist on her serpent
jacket and here's the surprising answer
madeline ketch told me when I asked her
about Cheryl's new family when you read
that Cheryl was going to be joining the
serpents what was your reaction
apprehensive okay I was definitely
apprehensive I don't want Cheryl to lose
her own identity
but I you know I had some talks about I
am I
she's definitely not going to listen to
me and then I was overall really excited
I mean for another jacket it was like
the coolest thing ever
now I need to know is that okay that she
shook up the colors a little bit we
won't let it stick I didn't think it's
gonna stick but I mean I'm letting my
girl have her moment we're just like
letting it happen it's like a little
special it's like you know it's her
little ceremony ceremony but you know
it's not gonna stick because she's not
gonna want to stand up she's gonna want
to blend in with the group you know
she's a new member and I think it might
end up becoming more of a family for her
what she needs she really so in hopes
that's where it goes you know obviously
I have no idea what's gonna happen in
season three yet but I'm excited for her
to have like a community and a home base
and a group of people who support her
which is what I think it is and that's
it riverbeds Wow all right that was the
finale we should be over right wrong in
fact I have two surprises for you now
the first is that we're gonna have one
final massive episode of Sweetwater
secrets coming next week
it's going to be a season to wrap-up of
hisses and kisses from me from you and
from the entire Riverdale cast it's
going to be so much fun so head on down
to the comments and tell me your top
kisses and kisses for the entire of
season 2 not just this episode and the
second and most exciting surprise I have
for you is I have a very special
announcement I'm launching a brand new
series on et's youtube channel for the
summer called ship vs. the only show
devoted to celebrating the best
relationships on TV now in each episode
of ship worthy I'm going to focus on one
of my favorite TV couples and the
premiere episode is all about Betty and
Jughead and guess what it's already live
so click somewhere and I've got
exclusive interviews with Lilly and Cole
that you've never seen before plus a fun
new segment called a naughty or nice
where I fangirl over the best moments of
their relationship so please check out
ship worthy this summer and get that
video like and then you can shout out in
the comments which other TV couples
you'd like me to feature on a future
episode now I'll see you next week for
our final episode of sweet water secrets
kisses to you river babes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]